okay wait so this is Kristin and she
just got six thousand nine hundred and
sixty nine dollars point six nine cents
from the stranger named Eddie Kristen's
other name is Kitty plays games welcome
to my stream my name is Kitty otherwise
known as Kitty plays games or Kristen
that's her twitch name twitch is a
website where you watch people stream
video games your following
it's actually free to watch but twitch
the company will select really popular
players and give them what they call
partner status
once you're a partner you can actually
make a lot of money from ads donations
and subscribers is amazing there's
something that's so special about being
able to directly affect the content mad
love for fishy right now thank you for
subscribing if I could watch modern
family you know and tell them oh that
was really funny right there you know
you did good like I love the one-liner
and then be like oh thanks Kristen you
know we worked really hard on it we're
glad that you appreciated it like
there's something really kind of
interesting in that sense with live
media twitch is insanely popular like
100 million unique viewers a month
popular and in 2014 Amazon paid almost a
billion dollars for the site and maybe
unsurprisingly 90 percent of the top
streamers are guys and most of the
audience is male so I wanted to know
what it's like to be a top female
streamer streaming to a male audience
and getting anonymous tips when I first
started streaming I had an addiction to
it I tried to me every single day you
know yesterday I stream for three hours
but last week I did a 17 hour store five
to six days a week maybe 8 to 12 hours a
day like my life is essentially like
community-funded saving up to purchase a
house it's very healthy I don't actually
know I don't make six figures just last
month I made over things like five
thousand just in tips it's kind of a
whole package deal with you know twitch
YouTube other brands and a bunch of
other things on the side enough for me
to not be in accounting or law right now
kitty told me that when she was 21 she
dropped out of university and moved back
home to stream on Twitch full-time less
than six months later she got that
almost seven thousand dollar donation
except it wasn't seven thousand it was
6-9 6-9 6-9 I don't know why that number
is a trend in my stream but it is now
and then one day I woke I woke up I
started streaming like any other day you
know I was like dressed coffee like
sporty clothes
not a special stream and assassin Andy
decided to donate that amount I spent a
lot of time watching girls stream on
Twitch trying to figure out in some
instances the difference between cam
girls and twitch girls and honestly I'm
conflicted are these girls being
empowered by making Bank on their terms
or are they being exploited as the
fantasy objects of guys who look around
cam rooms from Michael bell it says hi
Natalie I've been a longtime lurker and
just wanted to come out and say thank
you I've been going through a rough time
recently and has been great to come home
and have someone funny to listen to
enjoy your gift
one of the biggest stereotypes is that a
lot of the female streamers when you
first go into the chat you think that
you know they're these girls that are
kind of exposing themselves just for
donations or subscribers to make that
type of living for themselves when
people come into my stream I get that a
lot like oh here's another you know cam
girl I can't win when I am playing a
game and I'm focusing and trying to play
the game people in chat are like oh my
god she doesn't talk to her viewers like
this is a terrible streamer oh my god
and then when I'm sitting here talking
to my chat as a live streamer
interacting with you guys it's like on
your camera [ __ ] all you do is stamp on
your camera so it is extremely hard to
stay relevant yeah I just want to keep
it as focused around the gameplay as
possible which I mean for me wearing
full t-shirts every time definitely
works
the gaming industry isn't exactly known
for being super inclusive of women like
all internet personalities these
streamers have to deal with endless
endless endless negativity though twitch
is a little different streamers have
direct control over their chats and can
fire right back at their detractors we
don't deal with trolls in my chat
basically they get out very deep earlier
when I do talk back to like people
saying nasty things it's always
important to remind them you don't have
to watch the stream so in the question
of who's gaming who my bet is with these
girls
you know I'll roll with the punches the
trolls like come in there and they're
like show us your tits and I just rolled
them back and put a command in there I'm
like keep a tab open it'll happen so
then they sit there and wait constantly
like she's gonna show her boobs any
second few guys are so so typical but
I'm making money off of those trolls
just buy them lurking and watching so
I'll troll them back that way